bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france un mot pour commencer de cette
revalorisation salariale c'est une bonne
nouvelle
alors on va préciser ce n'est pas une
revalorisation salariale des professeurs
une valeur revalorisation d'une partie
des professeurs il ya 42 % qui touche
les héros d'un à 58% qui touche quelque
chose et la plupart des 29 euros par
mois les chiffres que donne le mini
pendant votre reportage au juste il
concerne les échelons 2 auquel les
enseignants est cependant un an donc la
majorité des enseignantes ont soit rien
touché soit touché 29 euros par mois
alors c'est pas des ro effectivement au
fait qu' on est en retard environ 2 900
euros par mois par rapport au reste de
la fonction publique de notre niveau
donc vous voyez que prennent ce matin
concernant le protocole sanitaire pour
cette rentrée c'est dans une semaine ce
que vous y voyez plus clair est-ce que
le ministre de questions vous a rassuré
le protocole il est plutôt clair que
tanner en à quel niveau 1 4 couleurs
donc c'est assez facile de s'y retrouver
ce sont la plupart du temps des mesures
que l'on est un peu près tout appliquée
l'an dernier donc on les connaît donc on
fait les appliquer qui ne manque ni d'à
part évidemment un investissement en
termes matériels et humains qu'on a par
l'investisseur ou euros dans l'éducation
nationale pour chérif au leader depuis
le début de la pandémie ce qui nous
manque c'est de savoir à quelle vitesse
sont annie terre correspondent tel
niveau de protocoles moi je peux pas
vous dire qui avec martin aujourd'hui
c'est logique qu'on retourne au niveau
jaune où il faudra être au niveau orange
j'en ai aucune idée parce qu'on ne sait
pas quel taux d'incidence quel taux
d'occupation des réalisations feront qu
on va passer d'un niveau à un autre
soucis et vous avez dit dans votre porte
à genté la gestion des cas contacts au
collège et au lycée puisque on se
retrouve avec un système très compliqué
où seuls les élèves qu'à contacter non
vaccinés resteront chez eux alors déjà
nous on ne sait pas crier lac ciné qui
naît avec ciné il va falloir se fier à
une déclaration des parents n'ont pas
forcément envie d'avoir leurs enfants
chez eux lors que les comprends c'est
compliqué à gérer
et on fait que ce qu'ils doivent rester
chez le staff n'auront pas courant
puisque les enseignants feront en
présente avec les élèves
trois ans carte donc on risque de se
retrouver dans un système où à l'école
primaire desquiens ko par la classe et
en collège et en lycée deck l'irak à
tous les élèves rentrent en classe
l'appareil quand même but là j'allais
dire par rapport à la gestion de la
pandémie alors jean michel blanquer a
fixé cet objectif de 600 mille tests
salivaires de dépistage
chaque semaine est ce que cela va dans
le bon sens pour limiter notamment la
propagation d'une variante delta est ce
que les familles acceptent cette
décision
alors qu'un chiffre réalisable au fait
il qu'on va déjà réalisés c'était le
chiffre que l'on avait à l'école
primaire avant les agapes n'était donc
100 mille têtes au de les faire on avec
les facilités de les faire et on sait
qu'à l'école primaire on a la majorité
des familles qui d'accord pour une
valeur qui a 100% on doit plutôt être de
l'ordre de 60 65 % mais c'était quand
même assez merci fin c'est important un
parc à l'école primaire je rappelle les
dernières donnent pas forcément tour pas
vaccinés et à l'école maternelle en plus
ils ne portent pas le match donc les
tests et quand même le j'allais dire
l'atout numéro 1 pour gérer la pandémie
à l'école primaire sachant que protocole
n'a pas changé depuis la rentrée
dernière globalement alors même qu'on a
le variant delta en collège et en lycée
c'est plus compliqué à on a vu qu'il y
avait des difficultés à faire accepter
des tests aux familles l'an dernier donc
de ce qu'on a compris on est plutôt sur
une politique ciblée qui a une
circulation prada qui les irrite quelque
part on pourra faire des campagnes de
tests et là aussi un jeu rappelle on n'a
pas le droit étaient les enfants qui les
familles ne donnent pas leur accord et
l'an dernier en fin d'année de colère en
lice et on était
de donner leur accord
alors au delà de ces tests à partir de
l'école élémentaire les élèves devront
porter un masque à l'intérieur les
établissements devront renforcer
l'aération des locaux est ce que cela
vous semble être des mesures suffisantes
pour limiter la propagation de
l'épidémie dans vos établissements
alors le film est de reconnaître qu on
avait la même l'an dernier au même
niveau un bel effet les élèves devaient
porter le mark il devait même les porter
à l'extérieur et la 1ère vous dit il
quelque chose de plus d'alléger c'est à
dire qu'à l'extérieur y a pas
d'obligation sauf si dans le département
ou la région il a été décidé que le
masque était porté à l'extérieur
donc c'est visiblement une mesure
importante à haut risque on ne va pas on
sait que le port du masque ça a un effet
anti bots s'endetterait pas toute sa
force et je rappelle que nous
enseignants ça fait maintenant un an que
porte le masque pour faire court et que
c'est pénible mais on le fait parce
parce que tu as fait quelque chose
c'est donc voilà c'est donc important
d'avoir ces mesures là l'aération
renforcer là on va se dire aussi c'est
de la blague moi je peux pas enlever
avec notre plus grand que l'an dernier
donc le rectifier l efficacité renforcée
avait pas besoin de le déranger pour
tard on aère l an dernier qu'on ait raté
l'année sachant qu'à des endroits où des
feux ne souffre pas trop mal s'ouvrent
peu et qu'il n'y a pas eu de grands
travaux réalisés dans nos écoles
collèges et lycées pendant les combats
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation jean-rémy gérard présidente
du syndicat national des lycées et
collèges